what's up elimination at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
to you that I want to see explode out
onto the world now I often get asked by
people I want to make money in my
industry I want to be the authority I
want to be the most recognized person
how can I attract that dollars to my
business and be the highest-paid expert
in my industry if that's you then you're
gonna enjoy this video so let's start
with tip number 1 which is get good a
lot of people are trying to become the
authority in their industry before
they're even really good at it and so
you need to apply an insane amount of
work to actually become one of the best
in your field and so the people have the
highest profile are not always the best
at what they're doing what they are good
right and so if I look at my youtube
career as an example I've made six
thousand videos right somebody told me
earlier today that you're such a natural
talent as he was watching me record like
I'm not a natural talent I just
practiced over and over and over and
over and over again I eventually got
really good and so I still have my path
I still have to get better but in your
industry if you want to be the
highest-paid Authority you have to be
really good at what you're doing you
don't have to sue me the most talented
but you have to be among the most
talented if you are a d level play or a
C level play or B level player you're
not going to be the highest-paid in the
industry so you have to put in the reps
is the boring part you have to be so
good that they can't ignore you tip
number two is get recognized for being
good so just because you're really good
it doesn't mean you're gonna get paid
the most and so part of that is building
up a brand building up Authority and
getting recognized in winning different
kinds of awards and so as an example in
my career I've been listed by ink
magazine and Forbes magazine as the top
speakers for leadership and social media
and a whole bunch of different things
that doesn't actually really resonate
for me I don't really care about those
awards but other people do other people
look at that and when they're looking at
we want to have a speaker to talk to us
about social media who are they going to
look for well
hey Forbes made this list of the top 40
social media speakers right now and they
go through that list right if I'm on
that list I get more money I get the
calls I get to charge more right and so
adding more of those Awards looking for
what you might be able to apply for any
kind of awards and also just being on
the radar of the people so understand to
reverse engineer those lists it's often
just one person making a decision
there's somebody who wrote that list and
so getting to know that person helping
them out follow them on Twitter respond
to their tweets add context to their
stories if they're writing about
something else can you provide your
opinion you want to be unknown quantity
to that person so that the next time
they're making a list they're gonna put
you on it a lot of it is still just a
human emotional connection there's no
easy way to make a list like that it's
not just dollars and cents it's not just
an easy easily quantifiable thing so
because it's so human dependent the more
you get to know that human who's making
the list the better chance you have of
getting on it getting recognized and
then getting paid more tip number three
is create where your audience is if you
want to really get the big dollars in
your industry you have to know where the
people in your industry are hanging out
and so we're gonna be creating content
that might be on LinkedIn if you're
selling the business I might be on
Facebook you might be on YouTube it
might be on Twitter you want to be able
to be creating content and be where your
customers are so you don't have to be
great on all the platforms especially if
you're just getting started in this I
think that's where people blow their
brains out too much they try to do
everything and then as a result they do
everything but in a really really
mediocre way and so you're not gonna get
attention for that pick the one method
where your ideal clients are spending
the most time pick that one method pick
that one social media channel and then
be great there if your ideal clients are
on LinkedIn as an example and they're
there multiple times every day and all
they see is your messages and your great
content and you spend a lot of time
making the best LinkedIn content
available using the expert knowledge II
you have because back to tip number one
you're really good at what you do then
you're gonna keep popping up over and
over and over again in their feed you're
gonna be a known quantity to them and
when they're looking at hiring somebody
to consult to speak to do a gig with
you're gonna be top of mind and they're
gonna want to pay a premium to you
because then
nowyou they recognize you to them you
are a brand name even though to the rest
of the world you may not be but to them
you are because you really hyper focused
on being where your customers are tip
number four is be prolific and what I
mean by this is you need to create lots
of content in your space so once you've
identified the platform that you want to
be an expert on if it's LinkedIn or
Twitter or YouTube be the person that is
creating the most valuable content
consistently and you're gonna stand out
more so for me it's YouTube right I
spend lots of time on YouTube it's a
great combination of my skills what I'm
great at what I love doing and where my
audience is and so yes I'm on the other
platforms and I'm building my team and
I'm creating more content around those
but it's nothing compared esand to what
I'm doing on YouTube where I'm making 3
videos every single day we've done over
6,000 on the channel not all of them are
public and it really builds up my brains
like if you are in the entrepreneur
space and you spend any time on YouTube
you've come across one of my videos you
just have you may not recognize my name
you may not have subscribed to my
channel but it's really hard to have
spent any time on YouTube and be
interested in entrepreneur person
development kind of stuff and not have
come across one of my videos and so
that's what you need to do in your
industry you pick the platform you know
where you want to be great at you know
what your message is you're really good
at delivering a message and now you need
to be prolific you're not posting once a
week you're posting at least daily at
least daily should be your bare-bones
and minimum for what is being put out
there now you don't have to create every
day I find that really taxing what I do
is on a day like this I'm making 68
different videos to create for you guys
and so we batch it so I'm here on a
Wednesday afternoon I'm making all the
videos for 68 videos from my channel and
then that gets cut up and sliced and
diced
over the next month right and so if
you're really good at what you do you
should be able to get in front of the
camera and talk about it you should be
able to sit down and write about it and
batch it spend an entire day whether
that's once a week once a month whatever
your schedule can kind of bear and then
you're creating content for that entire
week or for that entire month but you
need to be prolific hosting at least one
piece of content on the preferred
platform every single day with the goal
honestly to get to at least
twice a day that may not be happening
right now but that should be your goal
ongoing tip number five is speak you
want to be speaking at events where your
customers are hanging out it's so so so
critical important when you are speaking
at events whoever the speaker is that
person has authority why are you going
to this event you're there to learn from
the experts even if you're speaking for
free like the event may not pay you to
go and speak sometimes they pay you to
go sometimes they pay for your flight
and hotel but the speaking fee is free
sometimes they won't pay for anything
but you just being up on stage adds more
credibility and the people in the
audience look to you as the expert they
don't know if you've been paid to be
there they don't know how much you've
been paid or if they're comping your
hotel or travel costs or not all they
know is there's this person up on stage
who has this authority position who then
again back to tip number one be good you
have a really valuable message that
moves and inspires them to want to
change something in their life or in
their business you have a shot and now
you're a known quantity and you're in a
position of that authority they're going
to want to work with you to help them
solve a problem and so the more you can
speak at events and get your name out
there in that authoritative way as well
it really helps that number six is over
dinner like crazy one of my favorite
marketing strategies is through word of
mouth and you need word of mouth to
happen as an entrepreneur to get your
business going because you're not taking
out Super Bowl commercials you can't
afford to do that and so what you want
to do is have your customers talking
about you for you one you want them to
come back to you because you provided
such a great service that they're not
hiring you just for one thing but they
want to hire you again and again and
again again again but to there in your
industry they know other people in your
industry and if you provide such a great
service such a great product that they
can't help but talk about you then your
names starts to spread in the industry
and again it's not you talking about you
it's somebody else talking about you and
so it's much more likely to again lift
that level of authority for you get
contacts coming in and you can charge
your price to eventually be the
highest-paid in your industry
so you really need to over-deliver like
crazy look at what you have been hired
to do I didn't think how can I double
that triple that 5x that it may not even
cost you a lot of extra money or time to
do it
but it's the perceived value right I
remember for my first client my first
corporate gig I was paid $300 or $500 to
write a single blog post and I was up
with 10 or 20 other people who were also
paid the same amount and I just went
crazy on my blog post they wanted 300
words I gave them a thousand or 1500 and
I added a video and I promoted it and I
shared it to my list and I got attention
and awareness for that blog post and out
of all the people that they hired for
the first draft I was the only one that
they brought back to work with
continuously because what did everybody
else do they gave the 300 words of
content they gave what the client asked
for they did the job requirement but
because I went so far over and above
then they came back to me I wanted to
hire me and work with me more and more
and more and more not everybody else and
so you want to take that same approach
whatever the specs are whatever they're
asking you for you have to do at least
that's a bare-bones minimum like that's
unacceptable what they ask you for is
unacceptable you have to go way way way
above to win that client and then to
increase your prices
[Music]
and tip number seven is sell annual
deals I really hate doing one-off deals
if you want to be the highest-paid
authority in your industry what I always
try to do is if somebody comes to me
with a one-off deal okay we'd love to
have you speak at one event or hey we'd
love to have you make one video for our
channel hey we'd love to do one kind of
collaboration with you my default is I
try to turn that into an annual deal so
if you want to make one video with me
like you know what to actually get the
benefit if you want my audience to care
about you then we need to make this an
ongoing thing you're not going to get as
much value out of one video because that
video will be gone and then there won't
be the follow-up where if somebody hears
the message consistently over a period
of time they're much more likely to take
the action that you want them to take
and so I always try to move somebody
from a one-off video to at least an
annual deal if I look at sage as an
example you guys may have seen my videos
with Stephen Kelly he's a CEO of Sage
multi-billion dollar company we signed a
three-year deal so it started off as hey
maybe see if we can come on your channel
maybe we can do an interview you know he
loves entrepreneurs we'd love to have
him on and first of all your mission has
to be aligned I only work with Stephen
because he actually does care about
entrepreneurs because I actually do use
sage software in my business it's not
just a money-making thing I really
believe in what he's trying to do and
then we turn that into a multi-year deal
it's a three-year deal that I signed
with them where I'm helping them get
exposure and bringing value to the
audience and as you guys tune in pay
attention watch the show you learn more
about sage you learn more about Stephen
Kelly and the next time you're looking
for an accounting software package
you're going to at least give sage a
shot
and so by transitioning your customers
to being a one-off deal to think how can
I provide more value that this is at
least an annual deal if not have a two
or three-year deal it can really start
increasing the amount of money you make
because you have established yourself as
the expert and providing the same value
to your clients
so those are my seven tips on how to be
the highest paid authority in your
industry I would love to know from you
which tip resonated the most with you
what work do you have to do to get
better
is there an 8 9 10 that you want to add
to the list please share your thoughts
down in the comments below I'm looking
forward to hearing from you thank you
guys again for watching I believe
even you I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one where
it is much love I'll see you soon
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion can not one drop of
myself work depends on your acceptance
of me I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details